[Music]
hey everyone welcome
to another installment of harry potter
theory
in today's video we're going to be
discussing nagini
ron hermione and an unidentified green
curse
more specifically we're going to be
addressing two questions
number one did ron use avada kedavra on
nagini
and number two if it was in fact vada
kadavra
why wasn't it effective to get things
started
let's rewind to the end of the series
the deathly hallows part two
when the good guys are in their final
standoff with voldemort nagini
and the death eaters at this stage
nagini
voldemort's serpentine companion is
still very much alive
and has made her presence known at the
battleground the last of voldemort's
horcruxes
her presence there was certainly
questionable as if she died then it
would mean that voldemort could be
killed for good
voldemort however was not aware of the
fact that most of his horcruxes
had already been destroyed which was a
great position to be in
as far as the good guys are concerned it
gave voldemort a false sense of security
and meant that voldemort could be
content with nagini on the battleground
at one stage when the battle erupts ron
and hermione find themselves backed up
with nagini flying towards them jaws
open
it's at this point that ron points his
wand at nagini
and releases an unidentified non-verbal
green spell this raises the question
what spell
did ron cast the jet of light that came
from the end of his wand was green
and he certainly intended to kill nagini
but
does that mean that it was the killing
curse i'm conflicted on this
so i want to explore two possibilities
the first possibility
is that it wasn't the killing curse at
all just some other kind of green spell
this would explain why the curse
seemingly had little effect on nagini
and why ron was able to cast it
non-verbally generally
it seems as though stating the
incantation is necessary to perform a
vada kadavra
and i would imagine that this would
particularly be the case for someone
like ron
who never uses unforgivable curses the
second possibility is that
it was the killing curse but didn't work
for a number of reasons
first of all as outlined on numerous
occasions throughout the books
films unforgivable curses require
serious intent
you can't haphazardly fire crucio and
vada kadavra from the tip of your wand
and casting these dark spells can prove
to be particularly difficult
if you are generally a good person a
perfect example of this is when
harry uses crucio on bellatrix even
though harry was possibly angrier than
he had ever been after the death of
sirius
he still couldn't torture his murderer
regardless of the life or death
situation
he was faced with did ron really have it
in him to
kill i think that there's a very good
possibility that
it was the killing curse that ron used
he just didn't have it in him to use the
spell to its full effect
he didn't know how to use it or what it
meant to use it
and that's why it failed what do you
guys think
did you notice ron casting this
unidentified green spell in the films
let me know in the comment section below
if you enjoy the content
please like the video and subscribe to
the channel
until next time it does not do to dwell
on dreams
and forget to live